Hey hello and welcome to another video
this one is an ongoing story that I'm
working on I think it's quite the scoop
I've never talked about this before so
you might come quite as a shock it's
called the media it's stupid
got them parentheses not all media just
clickbait media oh boy oh boy where did
it all go from just like you I get my
news from the internet from the infirm
the interwebs that's where I find my
information on what's going on in the
world that's how I find out what is
going on on the next pretty Pi video if
you look on Google News essentially
there's a bunch of different news
outlets we got the Sun we got the
Guardian we got BBC we got Wired we got
Forbes they're all essentially competing
with each other but basically good oh
[ __ ] okay well this is a good title I
guess I click on that one oh how about
that there's an ad there okay great so
essentially as soon as I click they get
paid it doesn't really matter what the
content is as long as they have a good
enough strong enough title you know that
beats all its competitors then that then
they get paid so really the content is
pretty much irrelevant
they just need a strong title no matter
what and I know what you're thinking you
might be like okay well Felix you're on
YouTube everyone clicks bait on YouTube
but you're doing the same thing no not
really it's kind of different
first of all YouTube monitors watch time
so even if you have a clickbait video
and people don't actually watch it it
won't get us promoted you have been
promoting watch time more than anything
since 2014 and allegedly that's what
they say at least it's the first thing
that appears if you click on your
analytics literally you go to analytics
first thing that appears watch time
150,000 years have you guys been
watching my videos that's just kind of
sad isn't it but also a very important
distinction is that YouTube
entertainment media
it's the [ __ ] news it's supposed to
give you an objective standpoint on and
tell people what is going on out there
what is the truth you know I think this
is a bigger problem than a lot of people
realize because it affects actual people
it affects reality
it affects people like me and I think
that's why I've been bitching about it
so much anyway remember when the news
was sent to your home that was basically
subscription-based so the media would
get paid regardless so basically they
didn't have to click pay to get paid and
that way you get a more unbiased
objective news you could say hey maybe
you actually get in truth instead of all
this where whoever yells the loudest
gets paid now 2017 if the year it's
going to go bad for me all right I'm
just calling it out right right now
you want you get out before you can't
just put it pious he's a bad boy now
he's a he's a meanie he's terrible look
he's racist homophobic ain't you
anti-semetic
Oh what other labels can we put them
Hitler loving um white you may have
noticed there's been a lot of articles
popping up around me lately I'm just
gonna go ahead and say 90% of them are
negative the media wants to paint me as
some sort of villain right now oh please
please stop it's really annoying it's
confusing like old friends that don't
pay attention to what I'm doing anymore
and they're like wait you're racist now
I don't understand if that's the problem
isn't it unless you really know me and
what I do and you read these titles
about me you're obviously going to
believe what they're saying and people
just read the title anyway they just
want to put those labels out there and
to anti-semitic racist he said the
n-word all those kinds of [ __ ] that's
all that matters because that's how they
get paid my goal is not to keep pushing
these controversial topics what I just
think and I believe strongly in is that
it's 2017 now we're going to have to
start separating what it what is a joke
and what is actually problematic or what
actually fulfills the label or whatever
you're calling it is a joke actually
pure racism if it's something that would
can be considered joke actually pure
homophobic or all anti somatic and all
these things context [ __ ] matters
titles will never explain content and
that's that's the problem with all my
videos lately is that they take all the
stuff that I say out of context because
that's what's going to get them click
and that's going to get the mad which is
going to get some money
PewDiePie in anti-semitic storm after
paying men to unreal signs stating deaf
to all use hits YouTube you know and
they report on this and clearly everyone
is average it's a it's a huge
controversy International Business Times
the [ __ ] does that have to do with my
content it's almost like polygons in
Kakaako are sitting in the corner of my
videos when I come up say something bad
about gaming so we can get in on this
[ __ ] International Business Times like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about see
and even all the comments talk about it
like what a clash article nice grab four
views you hack I'm glad people at least
realize I and I'm really glad to see
that the majority realized how [ __ ]
these articles are and that they fulfill
no purpose whatsoever than to tear down
my name to get some more clicks online
so basically for those who don't have
don't know what happened I was [ __ ]
around with this website where you can
pay people to make messages and most
people said no to my request there was a
girls I was supposed to play hearthstone
with me and I asked her to play roblox
and she was like nope and and she didn't
fulfill the request there was a another
person but I was supposed to do a penis
in a and a masa masa grass and they said
no and but for some [ __ ] reasons
these Indian guys actually went ahead
and wrote deaf to all Jews on a sign
which you know there's something funny
about that
at least you know it might just be my
sense of screw
sense of humor but I think there's
something funny about that and I don't
think there's at any like the actual
anti-semitic thing about it again I
think there's a difference between a
joke and actual like [ __ ] deaf to all
juice if I made a video saying hey guys
PewDiePie here deaf to all Jews I want
you to say after me deaf to all Jews and
you know Hitler was right I really
opened my eyes to white power and I
think it's time that we did something
about it
that's essentially how they're reporting
this as if that's what I was saying or
some [ __ ] like that
another controversy was this
five-year-old that I made a made fun of
people hate on rival channel which
starts a five-year-old no I didn't make
fun of the five-year-old I made fun of
the mother running the channel but you
know that's not an appealing title is it
that doesn't get you as much fuses Rita
[ __ ] [ __ ] up a five-year-old three to
five one just quick Brian on that
five-year-old sat for fibro [ __ ] you
five-year-old if you actually watch the
video you would understand like I'm not
making fun of the kid but that doesn't
matter does it
it really doesn't matter at least not in
the title and you know what to the
benefit of the articles I usually do
mention it somewhere along in this
[ __ ] bread of text but if that
doesn't really matter because the title
is what people read that's like what 90%
of people actually read another big
controversy yet yes I know there's been
a lot of them was me flipping the n-word
in one of my videos basically I got
excited about becoming it and ranked 18
most handsome and I went 18 Knicks and
then it cut off before I even said the
whole thing but news articles of course
loving a bit of controversy they then
the son put it as PewDiePie slammed
after appearing to say I love this
censoring if you're going to say it just
[ __ ] say context matters its 2017 now
I think it's time for change
okay I know it's bad I know is going to
cause controversy
it kind of just slipped up because all
my videos are are improvised and I saw
it through editing I thought it was
funny with the way it was used clearly a
bad call from my part and I'm not going
to use it again mainly not because I
care if the word is bad or not it's
because people it just causes people to
lose their [ __ ] mind and it's just
not worth it like I don't get a kick out
of all this controversy it's not
something that I just be like oh [ __ ]
yeah look at all this attention that I'm
getting
Rober ah I'm not trying to push the
envelope I'm just trying to stay true to
my sense of humor and I'm not actually
trying to offend people with what I'm
doing
believe it or not you know if people are
offended that's kind of like well that
sucks for you
I feel like I'm digging myself a grave
this whole this whole video but I think
it's worth talking about so don't get me
wrong if I do something bad
and if I do something actually racist or
actually homophobic or actually with the
intent of it I do believe I should be
held accountable I'm not saying that all
media you know they're not allowed to
criticize me because I'm perfect and my
perspective is always what's better try
to vibe [ __ ] I should be called out for
it clearly I am NOT I have no problem
with that but I don't think this is it
and I really truly believe that these
articles slamming slamming people like
me for these topics they're doing more
harm than good they're doing more harm
than I'm doing by saying them I think I
I think being the political correctness
police is essentially just going to [ __ ]
us all over and this year 2017 I decided
I'm taking the stance back I'm going to
be true to myself I want to do this
sense of humor that I enjoy and this is
the price for it I'm fine with that
this video has really no point and you
guys know and I'm kind of preaching to
the choir right now I just want to say
thanks we're seeing through the [ __ ]
I read the comments I see that you guys
see me through the [ __ ]
and criticize just like I'm doing right
now and I think that I think that's
really cool thank you appreciate that
raises million dollars I'm charity
Benton world uses racial slur without
meaning here oh my god you're over put
pies over party y'all elect a racist
president but the oppressing to say the
n-word in a non negative way hey it's
almost like there's real actual issues
out in the world that you can actually
care about instead of instead of whether
a youtuber makes it slightly edgy jokes
and it's like I'm just barely this is
like the standard on the internet anyway
like people literally just care because
I'm PewDiePie and everywhere and
whatever I do is just going to be a
[ __ ] news article about it but
literally anyone else can say it and no
one gives a [ __ ]
I wonder what articles there's going to
be about this video pretty pie defends
himself after after saying the n-word
PewDiePie is essentially Hitler now well
hopefully I won't have to talk about
these anymore
I'm getting kind of tired of it I just
wanted to set the record straight that's
all